and you would support any of those
choices given the donors preference I
would support personally I find it's
easier to support those choices that
seem to be addressing the underlying
problem the challenge and if the people
who are actively involved in that space
our participants in the decision I find
it's much easier to support the
challenges are the Caprice of donors one
of the challenges and I find that it's I
believe that someone should be able to
spend their money as long as they're
doing no harm if they want to use it on
a plane or on ice cream be my guest if
they've earned it in an honest way but
if they're going to try to make the
world better I think we all have an
obligation to try to do that as
efficiently as possible and ask our
friends the questions that might help
elicit the appropriate answer and make
sure they're the right people in the
room what do you think well I have a
concern when one is advising the
super-wealthy the folks with outlandish
fortunes because should an individual
after they've paid taxes and so forth
that you've set up be able to effectuate
his or her own foreign policy you're
part of a country and the country has a
foreign policy but given your kind of
wealth I don't mean yours but but I mean
given once kinds of wealth you can in
fact become your own foreign policy
change maker that could be opposed to
the nation in which you're from does and
the end to me that tension is
problematic and that must happen with
some of the issues you've involved in I
see it all the time around the world to
me the solution or part of the solution
will be broad-based inclusive
representative democracy of well
educated populace if you have that it's
much harder for an individual donor
number
or what the resources are to effect a
change that's not for the BET public
good